what is going on there citizens the
reject nation greg here we're gonna
watch lord of the rings the rings of
power episode two
before any of that
how are you my my elvish friend hi
i
am stoic and uh
and uh
you know burdened with pearl i'm good
greg and we're good i'm excited to watch
more lord of the rings rings our powers
not landing today
stay tuned for more jokes like this one
forge that like button and fire people
also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next
l-o-t-r-r-o-t-p
[Music]
is up here on the channel
and also following through action watch
alongs where you sync up with the
timecode your own copy of the rings of
power available for our super sexy
rejects at our patreon page over there
we cover plenty of shows with the same
tier you get the option for reaction
heights and watch alongs included for
several shows we covered exclusively
lastly the team of prepper think about
setting down these highlights guys we
got an hour of setup to finish watching
let's get to it
[Music]
no she's gonna swim back to shore
good for her
prep her body for
fighting sauron you shouldn't sneak up
on folk like that
don't you lose her sam wise poppy
what is this your mom's gonna kill you
you're not telling her
neither am i
everyone should know about this i know
he's fell for the sky
i didn't go looking for this but you're
not turning away because i can't because
you won't
this stranger isn't a man
or an elf or some baby eagle with a
broken wing it was one time he's
something else superman
it's like there's a reason this happened
like
i was supposed to find him
i can't walk away from that not till i
know he's safe
she's my favorite character so far
no bodies
no wounded
perhaps they all fled
oh no that's a wounded body
damn we're crazy set
someone dug this passage something
warn your people you're not coming with
me i must follow the passage the other
direction you don't know what's down
there that is the reason i must go
oh you should have kissed her or at
least said something cool and elvish i
want to fill them with beauty to grow
beyond petty works of jewelcraft and
devise something of real power like a
ring what
is but a glint
on the far horizon you have come to a
region
to help me achieve
the how
the tower
oh
damn
have you considered seeking partners
outside the confines of our own race
how far outside like men
i don't want to deal with those men
folks all right they're all the same
this is going to become like there will
be blood
[Laughter]
just the difficulties of forging the
rings
might your friend be able to grant me
access to their workshops oh if i know
dorian he'll do far more than that
he'll welcome us with open arms
ram's horns blurry
it is el rondo of lindon
we seek an audience with prince dorian
i thought you were being sarcastic
you really thought that would happen
i invoke the right of
trust me
so these are the what will be the minds
of moria we're gonna see more the minds
in their heyday
wow
that is impressive
[Music]
beautiful music
that is crazy
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
and the unlikely events the elf should
win
which will glance a single boom
but should he lose banished
yes
understood
[Laughter]
chop chop
not bad
so it's just the endurance of how much
you can smash yeah just gotta keep it
going all day
hello
[Music]
what is this guy what
definitely sauron
[Laughter]
she's gonna rehabilitate him
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry
no
friend
just a friend
roy
it's your father
she's doing the chris pratt
[Music]
it's just disfigured and turning black
always ready for a fight
come closer
what do you think you're doing not
leaving her a drift supposed to be
sharing your rations
will not be our deliverance
don't litter on
us woman we got sticks together
i was separated from my ship and you've
not seen it
[Music]
wait until we can see the sails
corsair's prowl these waters do you want
to be skinned alive
that's intense that's no cool sushi
that's
our ship
oh
release the kraken
wow
oh that thing's just taunting you now
yeah okay she's your best hope
oh man it's bad luck to have a woman on
a ship
[Music]
oh my god she gonna ride it
yeah she's gonna tame it
wow that was a great shot holy crap oh
holy christ
this is an amazing shot
oh that was great i kept going like
underwater two times what are you called
aladria
from halbran
what's our head
two best looking people survived
[Music]
oh
it's rigged
the dog may bark at the moon
but you cannot bring it down
take your leave
why has it been a dick perhaps his
lordship would be willing to escort me
to the exit
gladly
you guys don't gotta play games just
admit you love each other the true
purpose of your visit you want something
i journeyed here to see my friend who
might greatly miss
you missed my wedding
the birth of my children do them
you cannot barge into my mountain of
demand i welcome you with open arms oh
he's just hurt
20 years may be the blink of an itin l
but i've lived an entire life in that
time
oh
a life you missed
you're too wrapped up in your work
elrond see that's how you make a
character very likeable right away yeah
or at least
i hope you can come to forgive me
and i would like very much to apologize
to your family as well
[Music]
one apology
and you're off
[Laughter]
you're staying for dinner he's leaving
he's staying he's leaving he's staying
hey
i told you to stay out of my head
make yourself comfortable
but not too comfortable
he's my favorite character
the dwarf durian there's a reason they
celebrate durian's day he's not here for
us his king sent him here to take what's
ours to the contrary
coming to kaza doom was my idea and i
have asked for nothing but your ears and
that's how it starts
[Laughter]
what sort of tree is it exactly
seedling
of our great tree in london some called
him a fool
for believing it would grow in such
darkness
where there is love it is never truly
dark
oh
you're not weaving already i fear i've
overstayed my welcome thank you diesel
nice nice fear of loss yeah pull away
let's say negotiate
shrewd
yeah sod it sit down
oh yeah great good job do you blame us
for you being stranded here the way i
see it wasn't elves that chased me from
my homeland
it was orcs
we must spread the word no i will not
have this gossip bronwyn osterith is
empty the watchtower abandoned i know
when i'm not inviting them elves back on
account of some sinkhole having them
gone as a relief
but for most of us anyhow
oh
that's what this is about
hey
wow crawl through that take some serious
commitment
[Music]
i mean the orcs right it could be that's
what i'm guessing
secret orc tunnel
god what a tight spot oh it's the
descent
i like it
much better ground water
[Music]
bringing a little bit of that horror
pedigree in here
come on
oh yeah
hold your mouth man
cool
oh
[ __ ]
oh
damn
oh the firewood stuff
ah
yes
[Music]
oh my goodness
oh my man
not bad dude
wants the blade
nice
so so sam ray if you use yourself
you're in that cut
[Music]
holy god
oh
[Music]
great eyesight yeah especially salt
water
[Music]
men and elves working together
i said it couldn't be done
now let's see if they can ride the same
bus
i wanted to help you
i thought i could but i'm sorry
great now he's going to yell at you
[Music]
is this some type of like sorcerer
is he like a proto wizard or something
yeah
he's got the hair and beard to be
[Music]
nori
is he like a vessel for something i
yeah
seems like he has like a link with the
natural world or something
elrond is a friend i trust him there can
be no trust between hammer and rock
eventually one of the other
must surely break
[Music]
tarantino
[Laughter]
yeah man that thing's like a beacon
it's like the ring
he's addicted to it
oh
oh blood activated don't do that don't
let that happen
grow that sword back you ready
yes mother
i'm ready
oh no
it's got its hooks into him
who's that i'm not sure
gandalf
definitely
the steel door
definitely
aragorn it's definitely all three of
them
wow before they all split up yeah
there's three kids in a trench coat
they're stacked on top of each other
i told you to take this
[Laughter]
quiet
boat
we'll take which boat i choose and you
will say nothing else on the matter
so gandalf always sounded that way
yes even as a young
man wizard
mckellen has always looked 88 years old
yeah
he's one of a long line of
prolific actors who have been old ever
since they were born
him and abe pagoda and patrick stewart
no not patrick stewart he looked young
once by comparison
fine steve buscemi
yeah
all right snap diggity
i like that episode so
much more
yeah like by a lot
yeah i would say that that definitely uh
uh
grew well out of the first one in an
upward trajectory i don't even know if
it's a great episode it might just feel
great by comparison
to that super shitty first episode
embarrassing first episode
no i know they when they release two
like this it's like they want you to
watch the second one to get a completed
package yeah yeah and um no it made
everything just so much better like i i
was i'm way more on board now
um and i'm i i mean i'm genuinely when
you cut two around to the stories i'm
like oh i'm interested in what's going
on like when
sometimes in when you have such a big
ensemble and you cut around the story
lines a lot of times i might end up
feeling in a in a way of
oh i've been cut away i don't really
want to watch these guys oh no i'm
actually into it but i noticed with
everyone they cut to i was always
interested i got a little pulled out
thinking about myself
oh yeah i'm i'm actually interested in
like everyone's story line holy crap
this is good this is good
and if greg's into it that must mean
it's all right that must mean it's
quality this means quality stamp of
approval
you guys are always free to like it now
yeah i'm known to be the one who doesn't
like anything yeah that's my reputation
yeah the guy
can't get on board with anything uh no i
thought it was great i thought this
introduction of um prince durin
was uh let's say pronounce it durin
with prince durran was excellent that
was like what i was kind of craving with
every character
from in the first episode
where i'm like no there's ways where you
can give a character a short
introduction and move the plot but also
get you to go like no that's that's a
character i'm on board with and i
thought prince whoever i don't know this
actor um
oh oh wayne wayne arthur
uh
but the character himself like that was
so refreshing
you know because it's like yeah the i
was making jokes but the the dwarves are
you know they they can be a little bit a
little arrogant and tough and and a
difficult wall to depending on the dwarf
you're talking to but usually if it's
like the prince or leader character
they're brooding
so it was like all right okay i get it
but then to see that his whole thing was
he was just he didn't want to feel used
that he was just upset for feeling like
a friend just never bothered to be there
for the important moments in life and
this he's just such a sensitive dude at
the end of the day
and also you know seeing like his wife
and that loving relationship they have
where they're just about to bang on that
table
uh was was great and the fact that he
you know he definitely kept elrond in
his heart by planting that tree too
i thought that was really sweet and
really touched in that scene was like
everything with them was excellent and
this episode also
significantly made elrond
a much more interesting character to me
too
like as if he's got something to prove
himself as well you know yeah i feel
like there's it's kind of it can be
tricky to make the younger version of a
character like that feel like somebody
that you can
i don't know me part way and who doesn't
feel like they're trying too hard to get
to the run we all know and remember
who's you know very lofty and ethereal
and authoritative like i like yeah his
characterization through the actor and
and two yeah the whole
relationship there just makes everything
that much better and two i mean watching
him play kimberly and legolas
that's right
it's proto gimli and legolas himalayan
legolas thousands of years in the making
and he's gonna throw him by the time the
season is done he's gonna have to throw
him at somebody but yeah like you know
all this stuff with uh keller brimboar
and them talking about
you know coming up with this
idea that like okay we need to turn to
somebody to help us you know with this
incredible task uh and
it made me think back
in a tangential way you know you have
the whole speak friend and enter thing
in lord of the rings before they enter
the abandoned minds and so here i
thought it was kind of a fun little
twist on that because yeah it's like
there is a pretense of friendship that
they're going off of
but then it puts you know elrond at an
immediate disadvantage and then creates
an endearing dynamic to watch as yeah
this this ailing friendship is sort of
being breathed having life breathed back
into it and uh and two i mean the way
that they realized the whole dwarven
kingdom was gorgeous
just their whole yeah all right
oh
i'm sorry i changed my mind then yeah it
was okay that's okay
i've seen better dwarven kingdoms
[Laughter]
in uh
in lord of the rings
but yeah no i i thought it did nicely to
bring him to a more personable into a
more
not like i feel like relatable can often
be kind of a cheesy word but but into
yeah just like a more human place as a
character i feel like you know the first
episode you already have these ideas
about who elrond is and why and he's you
know very personable at the get-go but i
like seeing him at a disadvantage and
seeing him put into this position where
he's like i
i'm not gonna win this rock breaking
contest i need to actually just appeal
to my friend and even the whole thing
where he's like i don't i don't get why
you're mad at me it's only been 20 years
what gives and then the whole thing
about time playing differently because
yeah it's a fast that's a great
conversation yeah totally
so yeah that that had the most character
richness across the episode and i really
appreciate it that feels like a very
lived-in piece of dialogue to me
so i really i really like that um so
that was my favorite aspect of the show
and knowing you know because obviously
the main thing we have to go off of with
the strongest memory is uh
because john you've listened to the
audio books it's like a combo yeah it's
like i've
i've
read chunks and and listened to all of
it yeah
and then with the hobbit i read in
both
yeah so
would you say you read more lord of the
rings or listen to more
well probably listen to more of it than
i would have read because uh i'm not
that fast of a reader and it's
not the breeziest reading material
well i mainly just have the movies to go
off of sure
that's that's the best of my
recollection would be is this kind of
doing a watchmen thing
where this is a prequel
to the books
not to the movies
you know what i mean
like i know watchmen is a sequel to the
comic book and not to the zack snyder
film yeah um so i'm i'm like is this
because there's so many peter jackson
influences
that are so present here
that i started getting confused on wait
a minute okay so this is all wrong
supposed to turn into freaking hugo
weaving
or are they just doing their own thing
you know that's a great question and i'm
honestly not sure i feel like there are
we live in a time where i feel like it's
the answer is probably murky in the
middle because they probably want you to
think of all the uh peter jackson stuff
and and i think they at least reached
out to him about this project and it's
like if you have howard shore credited
for certain music cues and stuff it
seems like there are
physical ties to those movies but i feel
like at the same time
it doesn't
have to be
i would air more towards yes it's trying
to connect to the movies than not but
i'm also not 100 on that is it like more
dead set on connecting to the books
than it is to the movies you know what i
mean that's because i know the movies
change some stuff
my best guess would be that they are
more concerned maybe
with connecting to the movie crowd
because i feel like it would be even
that much more of a hard uphill battle
to be like this
piece of you know streaming cinema is
gonna be the the canonical fill-in
between the books like i feel like
people would not entertain that
uh so i feel like it's a much easier
sell for people to be like this is
supplementary materials
gladly going lost
i'm not excited for this easter egg
because i didn't read that book
yeah
i don't know if we get some tom
bombadils in here or something like it's
the wrong era but you know if we get
some some
telltale piece of only book not movie uh
then maybe but yeah okay well
regardless um yeah because it feels it
feels like peter jackson's influence is
all over this
yeah uh whether and uh he and he wasn't
involved with the making of this but it
certainly seems like they took a page
out of how peter jackson adapted lord of
the rings and aesthetically
mirroring it you know even though i know
that like tolkien has had his own
drawings and stuff yeah to go off of
uh there's way more than just even like
the horror touches uh feel very much
like this kind of seems like how peter
jackson might do it yeah well and
there's connective tissue between peter
jackson and sam raimi in terms of
aesthetic style and so yeah that's
that's a telltale thing that says movie
to me also the design of the orcs looks
to be pretty close to the movie orcs
what i think is cool too is
the orcs were just like a quantity of
idiots in lord of the rings the films at
least like they were never scary to me
except for that one guy in fellowship of
the ring
um oh the urukai the urukai yeah um but
uh but the orcs in general are not scary
and here the orcs are actually scary
they actually feel like a real menacing
threat
that are ferocious and will
are
can annihilate you and they're a reason
to fear
versus in the lord of the rings movies
they're like
yeah you know you just get the right
people around they'll take them out no
problem you know
they feel like more like the hyenas from
like
movies whereas here they so far feel
like yeah these like feral creatures
that i think too just having less of
them and having them scattered around
and having these like run-ins makes it
more intense that way yeah yeah yeah we
got a lot of characters here and you had
uh galadriel
swam her way
to a life raft
that instantly got taken out
moments upon life lots of fun landing
there yep
what luck
that that sea creature that sea beast
was something
uh yeah i started thinking of jay i was
like wait a minute i know something this
guy directed yeah and and then it was
making me think of some of those
sequences in in uh in the beginning of
the following dominion
or
fallen kingdom yeah yeah my favorite
jurassic world movie because i love the
attention to detail in the shot when she
is swimming away and then like what you
because when the camera would
occasionally like go underwater like and
you would see the the advancement of the
motion underwater i thought was a really
great detail that was an incredible
sequence that that shot in particular
that would be so hard yeah because
you've also i love too that you also see
what looks i'm sure they could be cg
models but what looks like actors being
thrown around in the background when you
surface up
like there's so many little flourishes
and details that really sold that
yeah and i i like uh
i think because like what we're building
too is essentially the opening scene
this show is building to
is the opening of lord of the rings
right yeah with the battle but they're
still there
yeah
so
that could be a seal there on that boat
just using a different name
no no no no no the one in the shadows oh
duh
it could be
could be
yeah i don't know it'd be an interesting
way to meet him
yeah what's your name
it's
what's yours
i mean it's kind of cool to see how like
all that came to be
oh yeah knowing that there's going to be
like negative cons because because by
the time you know gim when the
fellowship of the ring happens you know
the dwarves and elves are still not
getting along and this is supposed to be
the thing of we can create a real truce
yeah
not a truce but uh
what was the specific word they said
i don't know something beyond alliance
yeah like we can really create a
partnership here in a way that you can
have like a pact a a bond of some kind
yeah yeah so having having them
knowing that like okay maybe they're
going to temporarily have that but it's
all going to fall apart yeah yeah
well and and something like this does
feel like and i've said i've felt
similarly about something like house of
the dragon which which has
much more of a direct sort of piece to
adapt but this is something where i'm
like yeah it doesn't feel like
certain prequels can feel like or mid
cools or whatever you want to call them
can feel like ah we need to come up with
something
to keep this going whereas here it's
like no that i mean there is writing on
this and it is another
you can see what would be gripping about
this phase in the history leading up to
everything with sauron and what we'll
see later in the third agency
definitely sure sure yeah yeah sure
don't be rude all right talking okay
[Laughter]
uh you're a wily one talking about
uh which one aaron dear
is that her name oh uh eleanor
rory
nori nori oh yeah i really like nori and
poppy's thing with with uh i mean i'm i
like the
the
they give them so much to do like the
guy you know who's fallen from the earth
and who has the whole thing with the
fireflies you know i like
charlotte copley from uh from elysium is
great
no i i like that though i mean i love
just the amount of commitment and like
you know those young actors especially
the one who plays nori like the amount
of like
half the time she's like on the verge of
tears as this sort of like
incomprehensible situation unfolds and i
like the immediacy of that and the sort
of tension of like everything happening
back at home and the slow unfolding of
yeah this guy who seems like he could
almost be some kind of early wizard
or something and uh and yeah like even
though the hobbits aren't you know or
the the harfoots aren't
so far the show is a true ensemble and
that i don't feel like anybody is the
central character so you know in lord of
the rings and the hobbit you feel like
you know you're usually with your
central people when you're you know
hanging with hobbits but but here i mean
too i still think they get all that
warmth and whenever you're in their
little village their little you know
nomadic township like i love those
flavors but also having the two of them
separate with this it almost feels like
almost like like the later phases of a
marion pippin story almost were like
their things get a little more serious
too
um yeah i don't know i i quite liked
that like i think my favorite i enjoyed
everything we cut to i think my favorite
bits and pieces were
nori and poppy and um
elrond and durin and then you know you
have
aaron dear and you have galadriel and
those stories are more straightforward
more action oriented this episode
but uh
there's something that feels uh
really fantasy cliche about
that whole thing with uh
hull brand
yes galadriel i don't know especially
when
the second i got that raft i was like
of course the best looking guy
he's gonna be the one that's gonna get
all those hair pulled out it's not gonna
be the other guy or the lady
no it's just gonna be the sexy guy i
think it's annoying cliche about fantasy
stuff to me yeah
what the [ __ ] do i want to watch ugly
people no no so come on
we already got the dwarves
yeah we're gonna put up with their faces
yeah
let's watch some more
yeah survive together in close proximity
i feel like the humans should the the
human the world of men should be
portrayed exactly smack in the middle
and everyone should be just okay looking
because the elves are all gorgeous and
the dwarves are you know like portly and
hairy and stuff the humans are gorgeous
too i'm saying the ones that we have the
humans should all be met at best to look
at like they got the hot mom i know
she's so hot
brownie
what's her name bronwyn
i'm a brownie
yeah yeah from how i met your mother
yeah yeah yeah it was a bronwyn yeah um
she had a great i love that sequence
with that oregon uh yeah their living
room yeah
yeah they go for some jump scares a lot
in this show mm-hmm
i think that might i think that makes
sense i think that works
it does it's fun it's uh
i think only one got me kind of
but most of the time i'm like
come on
well it's really predictable
and two i feel like a lot of times not
every time but a lot of times when
something that isn't primarily horror i
mean horror has enough trouble selling
and jumpscare these days but yeah i feel
like at times when other genres bring in
horror and do a jump scare sometimes it
can be easier to have that seem
telegraphed yeah
well um
yeah you got some cool plots left above
it there
son theo
yes
um he's gonna become uh
i know we're in grave danger their
creatures
ain't coming but yeah
yeah yeah i mean clearly yeah it is some
type of beacon that was let off with it
yeah and it like feeds on blood oh my
god an uh iron deer
dude's gone dude's in the descent
officially dead he's dead kill him off
camera forever they heard all that that
all those people who were like why is
there a black elf in this show
they they they uh they're like the guy
would kill him off the second episode do
something about that i gotta reshoot
this whole show we already have a black
dwarf
i don't know 30 million more dollars per
episode
black people must just exist in this
world i don't know
[Laughter]
yeah he's great i i think he does an
excellent job at um
he it's very few performers are that
great at like being interesting to watch
when they're barely speaking and he does
a really good job
at that he's really natural like
something as simple as like when he
climbed out of the water and whipped out
his knife yeah like damn he did that
like that like a real warrior yeah
something that feels so natural about
the way he did that like doesn't look
like an actor who trained yeah right
it's real natural and um
i love all the thoughts you could see
going on behind his eyes i think he does
a
really great job for a guy with not many
lines i i always find him really
compelling to watch no likewise he's got
a natural
intensity to him too
like when he's registering like there's
something at the ends of these halls and
he starts like um
hastening his way
out there mustn't make haste
i really i really like what he's doing a
lot i think he's really i think he's
really interesting oh yeah and it's easy
in the trailers i thought it was going
to be some just like cliche like
oh
yeah for something but like no i like
this brooding guy well yeah it's easy to
make but it's easy to fall into that bit
pitfall that trap but also it's easy i
think with this kind of character to
come off bland or come off you know just
sort of one note and yeah i agree like
he does
that he does all the the parts of that
character that you would want and enjoy
the the badass mystique of that but he
doesn't really seem concerned with being
a badass and so like there's something
yeah it's the the quality of the
performance combined with the fact that
he is just sort of so focused and
observant that does make him yeah like
even though we don't really know a ton
about him i am always like i just want
to keep on watching you
yeah
yeah
and uh
there's so much is happening
sometimes sometimes it's too it's credit
the fact that they cut around to so many
things and
sometimes it feels like it could be uh
because usually you'd be a build into
cutting around a multiple stories yeah
this show last episode was mainly
collateral but we're still cutting
around to a bunch of stories yeah and
it's maintained that cutting around to a
bunch especially into episode two
because in this one i was like oh
galadriel's not even being cut to the
lion's share of the time you know
she might be the slightest in terms of
screen time well since they gave her a
bunch in the last episode
yeah and i feel the main focus of the
last episode yeah true i feel like
in a show like that like so far i like
the time geography because
yeah it makes sense to me that while it
might not make every story every episode
equally compelling for the same reasons
i feel like
yeah you're gonna have some characters
who are dealing with a physical
situation at the same time as other
characters are dealing with a more
intimate diplomatic situation
and uh and yeah just sort of like the
breadth of
relevant places and the different things
happening but that all seem like they're
part of a growing sort of
malevolent happening within this realm
you know i feel like all
feels relatively well coordinated and
well thought out thus far anyway
yeah
why were people hating on this show
because uh you know not everyone's white
and uh the trailer lays out its steams
really bare so it's just like
i don't know people people thought it
was too woke you got men and women
kicking ass in this show i know and you
kind of always i don't know i mean yeah
lord of the rings had arwin
and and
i mean i guess it's not as prominent of
like there's leads and stuff but yeah i
feel like you had a lot of different
diverse but
main female character flat out god saved
by a man in this episode
well you have to remember that everyone
who's been hating on this show has not
seen an inch of it
that's true just a couple of trailers
that's true
so
everyone's like oh first black dwarf not
on my watch watch the flip half and
repeat before now it's the the woke
crowd
who's like
i hate this show i can't believe the
main female character was rescued by a
white man and clearly set up that she
wouldn't need him what does a woman
always need a man in every situation
yeah i don't know people people people
fans especially i think fans of book
series because there's something i feel
like that's more you you get a license
to feel more academic like i have read
and dissected these and with tolkien too
there's
you know
he
wrote novels but also wrote histories
and and you know uh uh
linguistic texts and stuff about this
world so i feel like there is an extra
uh ability for lord of the rings fans to
feel
you know
uh
kind of like
experts among
casuals a lot of this show seems to be
dealing with conquering prejudices
well and there's always been an element
at least
from what i can recall you know you have
the squabbles between the different
races and things like that yeah so
and i mean here they're not like
stopping everything to make it some kind
of 2022 race relations allegory
you know that depends
that depends
i think there's a lot of commentary
about police brutality that's right
sauron is just uh is just a sheriff he's
just a corrupt sheriff and his whole
police force just doesn't give a [ __ ]
and they're just abusing their power
left and right
all these police orcs out here
just taking it out on the well you know
that folk theo is
you know what that sword is it's a
metaphor for cell phones that's right
that's his social media right there
that's right it's just consuming his
mind and turning it into mush he doesn't
know how to interact with anybody out in
the real world
he's gonna have no real world skills
i'm telling you man metaphors i know
[Music]
art is open to interpretation and i hate
it i hate interpretation
i hate what i interpret art just a
definitive text and nothing more
until i write some head canon fanfic
about it but that's different story guys
this is the best show of all time
i i'm intrigued i'm enjoying it and i
hope it keeps developing
i hope it uh keeps expanding uh yeah man
for sure listen guys
mel brook should have been the main elf
i mean uh dwarf
yogurt
your schwartz is as big as mine
got to forge the biggest schwartz
and all of middle east i gotta forge the
schwartz crystals
gotta smash these stones with the
schwartz
you'll never smash as many stones as me
you lost it yeah i know you sanded too
hard yeah he went into a different yeah
and then
new york instead of jewish yeah
definitely uh
you got to know what every single jew on
the planet sounds like john
and be able to channel all of those at
the same time
yeah into a mono it's a hive mind yeah
it's mind of judaism
the hive mind
the hive mind
that's that's my contribution for the
day
i joke about that with my buddy all the
time oh really
you have a jewish friend
one i limit it
bingo card and once your slot's full
it's full until we
decide to not be friends gordon's also
jewish too oh you can't be friends with
him now nope nope spots already taken i
know
yeah
it's a bit too bad i liked andrew gordon
yeah but you know
let's face it man outron only has like
one doorframe
i have a dwarf friend you guys
i'm gonna ask my one dwarf friend for a
favor
all right this video is done
not over here ever
i'll talk to you soon bye
[Music]